because God Only Knows I'll tell you
this
man those door Dash people see some [__]
oh god dude first of all lest we
forget the people that have had to go to
people's homes
brother they have to go into the
trenches of well sometimes they get
killed sometimes people kill
them sometimes you have a burrito in
your car and you're driving it to
someone's house and that is going to be
the last thing you do on this Earth the
last thing you do is walk of soggy
burrito to a guy's house and instead of
just taking the burrito and saying thank
you he goes I'm gonna kill you now yeah
he and he then they kill you yeah they
say welcome to Memphis brother welcome
to Memphis and the crazy thing is a lot
of the people inside who know they're
going to kill you yeah as you're walking
up murders have gotten so advanced with
like Ambiance and production that they
will even play There Goes My Hero right
from like a yard plants speakers hidden
in yard plants as you're about to go and
then as he go and you're laying there
and you're bleeding out and and you the
one of the last thoughts you have is
this song is great this is a great song
yeah and I'm sad I won't be able to hear
it anymore it's the last thing I'm
hearing and then you see that burrito as
you're bleeding out just look at it just
that burrito yeah it's a tough gig a
hand just comes in a frame and grab yeah
it's a tough gig people don't want to
talk about the real Turf War that's
going on Tim and that is between door
Dashers and the homeless yes well
because if you're homeless if I see a
door Dasher I see I'm seeing an
opportunity that's all it is that's all
it is if I by the way door Dashers now
are are they don't let it be known
they're door Dasher they are stealth
like food delivery people are stealth
they'll dress up like post postal
workers vampires vampire yeah you don't
even know who they are they're in a
costume they're in a truck I see
somebody just wandering like sometimes
they have their friend with them as a
lookout have you seen that there lit be
be a guy in the front seat of the car
and then his chick will be just kind of
looking out just making sure like nobody
comes and kills him how crazy that door
Dashers yeah it's crazy yeah I mean and
they are also carrying messages here's
the thing I don't feel bad for any of
them yeah because I don't know anyone
who does it and I do
believe anybody who's doing door Dash
has is is like you know in India they
have a cast of people called The
Untouchables do they really yes you just
can't [__] with them you can't go near
them you see them and you look away uhuh
that is kind of and this to no no don't
take offense to this but it is when I
encounter a food delivery person in the
wild I I don't I look away no I will
look away damn you don't feel like
you're one of them a food delivery
person no yeah I just there's so many
other
jobs I just feel like if you're
delivering door Dash I just inherently
here's the thing I I I love them as a
person they're child of God yeah but
they're in so much pain are they a lot
of times you can see they're in pain I
can't see it really they're just
listening to Scott sta usually I don't
feel no they're I think some of them are
in pain they're just it's tough It's A
Hard I just it's hard for me to see and
look at it's just hard for me to look at
well we make them the saddest part is we
make them drive too it's like well yeah
they're a victim to gas prices at least
in other countries they like door
Dashers will be on motorcycles or
they'll just be throwing the food to
someone who's further down the street
they're actually cool yeah because many
of them are are Asian and they're on a
tiny little bike and it's fun yeah and
they're having a great time and they're
actually seeing how fast they like yeah
seeing how fast they can get it to oh
there's a dark web of that they are all
on where they get points and they little
oh and they like seeing how and many of
them are risking their life with Ramen
on their back yeah to get it to you
they're risking their life so that an
NYU student can eat that Ramen piping
hot you're getting it so hot but in LA
maybe I should qualify my statement yeah
it's only door Dashers in La of course
cuz there were people that want to be
like actors or screenwriters they're
lazy the food's cold you barely get it
yeah that that's my issue here it's not
I don't want to malign all the food
delivery people in Los Angeles I've
noticed a problem sometimes they'll just
steal the food yeah now that's another
thing take the food yeah some of them
are just looking to get a meal because
you can apply online yeah you can be
working for door Dash in six minutes or
less that's one of their big things like
yeah in six minutes that's not a good
idea yeah it's a horrible idea a
horrible idea become a door ass delivery
guy in six minutes yeah you can be a
door Das deliver guy in six minutes like
or in a very small amount of time I'm
not sure what it is but and they call
you an independent
contractor um but yeah next thing you
know you can be you can have a food in
40 minutes you can be picking up food
from somewhere that you can just
eat yeah I mean I've had some issues
with them have you well I actually door
Dash now I I think is pretty good it's
the one that I use what I thought you
just said all this [__] well no they are
they're bad but they're all bad like
Postmates is they're all different kinds
of bad yeah Postmates is bad uh Uber
Uber Eats I just feel like it's a monop
I don't want to be involved Uber Eats is
disgusting I don't want to be involved
with people that are double dipping yeah
I agree it's sick you know it's sick but
to me it's like door Dash even though
it's evil it's the lesser of all the
evils yeah or you could leave your house
but that's terrifying to go go in like
the the process of getting oh to go into
the world yeah it's crazy and to go eat
like well like David Spade still eats at
McDonald's you know he's basically he's
like the ulses S Grant of our time I
feel like like he goes he's on the front
lines he is the ulyses S Grant he will
sit in there D he'll battle he has an
amazing story about battling a homeless
guy for a series of nuggets that he had
ordered well that's probably
what keeps a guy like that who's so
successful and so beloved it's what
keeps him grounded yeah like once a week
he goes I got this legendary career but
he's like once a week let me go and get
a MCG griddle yeah and see if I can make
it out you know and if he can make it
out with a McGriddle he's like all right
it's just we all need a little friction
in our life like this is for you Farley
yeah this is for you and he goes in you
know it's just he's like Adam Sandler's
on a spaceship somewhere you know like
writing movies from a space station and
David Spade's like let me just go into
the Las Siena McDonald's and just see if
I can get out today with a McFlurry get
into my car yeah like there was a guy
last night in I was driving on Santa
Monica in West Holly at West Hollywood
and he was just running darting because
they Dart across like the street well
it's risky for them and they just Dart
across the street and he had a
skateboard with no wheels he just had
the board oh yeah and I didn't
understand what that was and he just and
he he had it and then he just in the
middle of my car just stopped and looked
at me like hit me wow and I was just
like I don't want to I'm not trying to
hit you know it's people looking for
accidents it's people that were just
like kind of like I don't know what it
was he was like a deer in headlights God
and I just swerve around them but it's
like people just mentally aren't
together and they need help someone
needs to help them they their people are
missing their wheels they're they don't
have their wheels and someone needs to
like step in there and help and like go
like hey man what's going on but the
only people that they're encountering
for any sort of guidance are door Dash
It's door the door but here's the thing
at door people by the way earlier on I
said you weren't human beings by guns
forget that yeah that was crazy because
I I here's what I meant by that we need
you now more than ever amen because what
you need to do is rise up you are the
therapist you the therapist homeless
people if there's somebody that is
homeless and is having a problem on the
corner you need to put the ramen down
put the ramen down and go address the
problem what's going on sir I am a door
Dash
professional yes I'm a licensed door
dasc professional food delivery service
professional can I assist now this
person is going to be yelling and
pointing at something that isn't there
invisible yeah it's going to be going to
be pointing at something in this
Dimension you cannot see so you're just
going to have to let bear with them bear
with them it's not going to happen first
question you go are you on any
medications right now have you taken any
drugs yeah got to ask that in a
non-threatening way 100% yeah and then
you're going to need to you will be
equipped with markers and paper you're
going to need to get these people to
draw a picture of what's Happening of
what's happening and then a a separate
picture to calm them down of their
ancestors no for sure these these social
workers aren't equipped they're not
equipped anymore and they don't want to
do it and they've also given up a lot of
them are just creating uh profiles
social profiles a lot of social workers
are also doing only fans so they get
clients confused you'll have a therapist
log on to his zoom and just start
showing their Buttle yeah and it's like
what because the last thing a homeless
person wants to find out cu like can you
imagine that you're homeless you got the
big Cape yeah and there's this guy in
trebeca where I spend some time
sometimes has a big cape the government
bought it for him yeah he has like that
big furry Cape oh yeah and he's they
kind of bedazzle him kind of like they
do those Fab eggs he's kind of like a
Game of Thrones guy and he's in the
winter he's kind of it's not a bad look
it's kind of like stat but then like you
know he's always kind of rapping to
himself he's always got his headphones
he's kind of doing that back and forth
yeah exactly and then the his social
worker comes over he's like hey what's
going on and then if he's like [__]
aren't you and he points her a photo on
only fans immediately she has no
credibility yeah aren't you chatty [__]
30 you're right you have no credibility
I'm watching you right now yeah I'm
watching you right now finger yourself
so and then you come to me and you ask
me what's wrong I could ask you the same
question what is wrong so that's where
it's going to be it's going to be
homeless only fans social workers
chatting with door door Dash
professional Prof door Dash clinical
door Dash Patric professionals and then
we need highly trained spgs Sil back
gorillas so that they know when it isn't
isn't appropriate to step in and calm a
homeless person down by sitting on them
outside of a Five Guys yeah yeah that's
it and that is our that's not a bad idea
that's our campaign brother it's not a
horrible
idea